Whiplash quickly
um
I there's few roles not not many roles
that I've seen where I say
not that I I can't do it but how did how
did he do that how
like it seems almost impossible like the
role you played the the dialogue the
snappy you know the the turning on a
dime emotions changing boom boom boom it
was it's not just to me the best
performance of the year that you won the
Oscar but and I'm not kissing your ass
it's just a fact that I know a lot of
actors most actors would say it was one
of the best performances I've ever seen
in anything I've ever seen and I just I
mean what was your work ethic to prepare
this
well I I've been preparing for that my
whole life you know when I first met
Damien Jason reichman sent me the script
for the short and the feature film of
this thing called Whiplash by this kid
nobody had ever heard of I have uh uh by
this time I'm in that position where
we're like I'm not auditioning quote
unquote but we're gonna we're gonna go
meet right we're gonna have lunch I'm
gonna meet this Damien Giselle now first
of all I read this script
and it is you know
up there with you know A Few Good Men
Juno it's up there with the most
brilliant things I've I've ever read and
potentially had the opportunity to be a
part of including Shakespeare and
everything else I did over the years
so I want to do it and this is we're
having a meeting to to spend a three-day
weekend making a short film for which
everybody's gonna get paid 173 dollars
but it none of that matters because it's
sheer Brilliance you know and I and I
want to be a part of it
we we set up a meeting to at the old
Daily Grill which no longer exists we're
in the top floor yeah of course we're
gonna have lunch there and I have this
image of Damien chazelle
it's a it's a brilliant brilliant script
obviously written by somebody who has an
inside understanding of jazz music and
what it is jazz music a quintessential
American art form
particularly African American art form
and Ice I hear the name Damien chazelle
and I'm going to this meeting and I'm
looking for Antoine Fuqua right I'm
looking for some big tall impressive
black guy with a you know Beret or
something that's that's my impression of
who Damien chazelle must be having
ridden this you know
and and I'm I get to the Daily Grill
like right on time and I'm looking
around
and I don't see Antoine Fuqua and and
then this you know this
skinny little kid from Jersey you know
kind of raises his hand and God JK and I
go
oh
wow okay hi Damian Giselle how are you
we sit down you know we start doing the
mutual admiration thing and one of the
first things he says is I wanna
I want to take the onus off of you as
far as the technical aspect of this
character because I want you know I want
you as the actor okay if you you know
we'll have a technical advisor we'll
have a body double who can do the
conducting and the long shots you know
he said don't worry about those aspects
of it and I looked at him I'm sure a
little bit oddly and I said
dude I
I went to music school I I have a degree
in music I thought I was going to be
a composer and conductor oh my God and
my father was a choir conductor you know
his entire career I said
that that's you know and and he was like
you know there's there's some kuzmet
going on here that's amazing he also
wrote it uh with Miles Teller in mind he
didn't write it for me he just when
Jason suggested me he went oh that's a
great idea
um he wrote it with miles in mind not
knowing that Miles had been playing
drums and cheesy rock bands You Know
ever since he was in eighth grade so I
mean the combination of uh you know a
lifetime
of of preparedness that brought the
three of us together on on that project
was you know it really was one of those
just just meant to be